dive into the world of infrastructure as
code with this Hands-On course by
rishabh Kumar who will guide you through
the essentials of deploying a website on
Google Cloud platform using terraform
through this course you'll gain hands-on
experience deploying a fully functional
website on Google Cloud platform you'll
learn to write terraform code manage
Cloud resources and handle custom domain
configurations all while understanding
the principles of effective and
efficient infrastructure management
by the end of this course you'll be well
equipped with the Knowledge and Skills
to leverage terraform in creating and
managing scalable and automated
infrastructures on the cloud so let's
begin today I'll talk about the famous
infrastructure as code tool known as
terraform and will deploy a website to
gcp which is the Google Cloud platform
and if you are not familiar with
infrastructure as code it is one of the
important devops principle which allows
you to deploy your infrastructure to any
of the cloud providers using a code file
which makes automation easy
so let's dive into what we'll be needing
today so for the requirements first of
all you need a gcp account which would
allow you to deploy resources to the
Google Cloud platform you'll also need
terraform installed on your Dev machine
and since we'll be deploying a website
you need a domain name that we can point
our website to and at last we also need
the gcloud CLI installed and
authenticated on our Dev machine going
over the architecture diagram this is
what we'll deploy today
so if any of the users try to visit our
website Cloud DNS which is a gcp service
we'll handle that request of whatever
our domain name is or go to the CDN
which is again gcp service known as
content distribution Network
and then we'll be using a cloud load
balancer to forward those requests to
cloud storage where we will have a
bucket containing our website content so
this is the architecture diagram gives
you kind of an overview of all the
resources that we'll be needing today in
gcp to deploy our website so before we
start with any terraform code
I want to make sure you have your Google
Cloud account set up so if you haven't
created an account you'll need an
account with active billing even though
the cost for this project will be
minimal since we are using Google Cloud
Storage to store our website content
couple of cents for that per month but
you can incur charges for your load
balancers as we saw in the architecture
diagram that being said you still get
some credits you also get a free tier
from Google Cloud so for your Google
account what you want to do is in order
to manage the resources efficiently you
have projects in Google Cloud so you can
go ahead and create a new project after
you have created your account for you to
deploy the infrastructure so I have
created a YouTube Project here as you
can see and have selected that
Google Cloud gives a random project ID
or you can choose your own project ID
and I have selected that as my project
for today's course now there are a few
apis that you have to make sure are
enabled so you need Cloud DNS API since
we'll be using a domain name you also
need compute engine API since we'll be
using the load balancer and you also
need IIM API and I'll tell you why in
order to enable these apis on your home
page of the project you can see there's
quick access menu and you have API and
services
if you click on that you'll be able to
enable different apis and services
so you can search for cloud DNS API
and as you can see
it shows up the cloud DNS API on my
project it's already enabled but if you
don't have it enabled here will be a
button saying enable this API similarly
if we search for compute engine API for
our load balancer
we can enable that too
and then last but not the least is IM
API
so make sure all these apis are enabled
and we need these in order to proceed
with our project today so after we have
done that what I'll do is create a
service account for terraform to
authenticate to Google Cloud since we'll
be using terraform to deploy our
infrastructure for our website it needs
a way to authenticate to Google Cloud to
deploy that infrastructure and the way
it does that is through a service
account
there is a documentation available from
Google Cloud on how to create a service
account and I'll make sure it's linked
down in the resources below
but I'll just show you how you can
create one
so if we go to service account which is
available in IIM and admin and if you go
to service accounts you'll see that I
have two service accounts here let's
click on create a service account
and now you can name this accordingly so
let's name it free code Camp Dash
terraform and then Google Cloud will
also sign it a service account ID
and you can put in the description
saying terraform gcp
and then you can click on Create and
continue where It'll ask which role you
want to assign
so I highly suggest you fine grain the
access that you provide the service
account
since I showed in the architecture
diagram that will be using Cloud DNS CDN
load balancing and cloud storage you can
limit the access for this service
account only for those Services by
searching for those Services here but
for the purposes of this demo I'm just
gonna go with basic and click owner but
you can see there is a message saying
full access to most Google Cloud
resources see the list of included
permissions if by mistake you expose
your service key
which will generate and store today for
our terraform project if you expose it
publicly you have the risk of
individuals having access to your entire
Google Cloud account so make sure you
have fine-grained your access to this
service account
but I'll choose owner for the purposes
of this demo
so I have given the owner access and now
we can click on done and you can see it
generated a service account called free
code Camp terraform
so now we'll need an API key for this
service account and how you can do that
is by clicking on Keys click on ADD key
create new key and let's go with the
Json format it's also the recommended
format by Google Cloud
if you click on create what I'll do is
ask you to save the key locally on your
machine let's do that and then once we
get to the terraform part of this where
terraform needs to authenticate and
deploy infrastructure to gcp I'll show
you how you can use this API key but
yeah this was how you can create a
service account and we also created the
terraform project inside gcp and we
needed to enable Cloud DNS compute
engine and IM API now let's go with
second requirement that was installing
terraform so I'm on the official
terraform website from hashicorp and
installing terraform on Mac OS is pretty
easy you can just use Homebrew by typing
the command Brew tab hashicorp tab and
then Brew install hashicob slash tab
slash tariff so let's go ahead and do
that let's copy the First Command and go
to our terminal
paste it
and let's copy the second command which
will install terraform
and there we go so I already had
terraform
1.4.6 installed which is up to date so
that's why you're seeing that message
but in your case if you don't have
terraform installed Brew will go ahead
and install it for you so now let's
start writing some code what I'm gonna
do is go to the right directory
on my Dev machine here and then create a
new directory called terraform with gcp
and let's open that up in vs code
okay so I have the directory open here
in vs code and as you can see it's an
empty directory so let's start with
creating a folder for our infrastructure
and let's name it infra I'll start with
the fundamental terraform file that we
need which is usually named as main.tf
and this is where most of our terraform
code will go but we also need to pull
the provider gcp from terraforms
registry and I'll show you how you'll do
that and the best practice is to have it
not in main.tf but another file called
provider.tf so let's do that right now
as we are starting so provider.tf and
we'll bring the gcp provider in this
terraform file so let's start writing
some HCL so I'm just going to make a
comment here saying gcp provider on the
top and then what we are going to do is
pull that Provider from the terraform
registry so provider
and then we'll go with Google as our
provider
and we also need to specify some config
for this provider
first off it is the credentials so this
is where our service account which we
created before will come in
which will allow us to authenticate to
gcp
and a project so what project should the
infrastructure be deployed in and as you
can see I'm using VAR here which stands
for variable which basically means it
allows us to assign variable values and
not hard code it into the provider
column here so let's go with gcp under
project and you can name your variables
accordingly
and last one is region
which for me the nearest One Is Us East
one but we'll Define that in the
variable files that you'll see later
and there we go
so we have our gcp provider pulling in
into provider.tf
let's go back to main.tf and let's start
with creating a cloud storage bucket
where all of our website code will exist
so let's start with a comment saying
bucket to store website
and then let's create
resource and you can do that by typing
resource
and let's go with storage
underscore bucket
and let's call it website since we'll be
using it as a website hosting so there
we go we created a resource called
bucket and then provider
you can specify that if you're using
multiple providers in your provider.tf
file or you can leave it if you only
have one provider which is in our case
so let's go ahead and
delete it
so now let's name our bucket
and again you can use a variable here
but I'll just go and name it example
website
by rishab
that's a long name I feel like it'll be
unique make sure you choose a bucket
name that's unique because they need to
be globally unique
as per the instructions by gcp and then
location is us for our bucket
so we have just created our first
resource in the terraform file mind you
it hasn't been deployed yet and you'll
see how you can do that later but let's
go ahead and we'll need a index.html
file that will upload to this bucket and
I'm gonna cheat here a little bit I
already have
index.html that contains my Social Links
like Twitter GitHub LinkedIn Instagram
and I can show you locally here but I'm
gonna use that and upload it to this
bucket so let's create a folder here in
our root directory called website
and in that website directory I'll have
an index.html
and this will serve as our code for the
website
okay so this is the index.html I was
talking about I can show you locally
here how it looks like how the website
is so I have a local server running and
if I go to localhost code 5500 you'll
see the website
so this is the website that I was
talking about nothing fancy simple
index.html with some Social Links for
myself
and remember if you're using gcp cloud
storage bucket to store your to host
your website it needs to be static it
can have JavaScript and CSS but you
can't host a dynamic website on cloud
storage so there we go we have a simple
website that will deploy to gcp using
terraform
and now
let's come back to our terraform file
and upload this index.html from local
storage to our bucket and how you do
that is by creating resource for object
so items in a bucket are known as
objects so let's do that I'll create a
comment saying upload e HTML file to the
bucket and let's create that resource so
resource and then we'll be using Google
storage bucket object
and we'll name it static
underscore site underscore source and
now let's name the object itself so this
name represents what the object will be
called in the bucket and not locally and
now we can Define The Source where this
object is being uploaded from so in our
case it's the root directory and then
website and then
index.html and you also have to specify
which bucket you want to upload this to
and I'll show you how you can use
in order to use our website bucket that
we created on top we can just go ahead
and do dot website dot name so that we
don't have to hard code it I'll just
grab whatever the bucket name is which
is example Dash website Dash by Dash
reship this helps because if you used a
variable here and you created a
different bucket name your code will not
be broken if you're hard coding it here
so that's how you do that in terraform
and one key thing to remember is since
we'll be hosting a website are objects
in the bucket need to be public
so let's go ahead and do that by
defining an object access control so
let's do that before
we upload the object so make new objects
public
and since I won't be using this bucket
for anything else I'm fine with having
my index.html publicly accessible but
make sure you know what you're doing
don't upload sensitive information to a
public bucket so resource and then this
time we are creating an object access
control so Google Google storage object
Access Control
and we'll name this public underscore
rule so by now you
might have realized that first we have
the resource which the terraform will
call to the provider's API so this is
all defined by the gcp provider how to
create a storage bucket how to create a
storage object so all of this naming
convention is predefined by the gcp
provider and you can read about it in
the gcp provider documentation available
on terraform's website whereas the
second part of the resource syntax is
the name that you're giving to this
resource in the terraform file so this
is not the name that will be on gcp but
it's the name that terraform knows it
has and then gcp itself will have this
bucket name that we defined for that
resource
so just trying to explain the syntax of
terraform so now we are creating the
object Access Control let's go ahead and
Define our object here so again we'll be
using the index.html name but we can do
is Google storage underscore bucket
underscore object dot static site source
and Dot name so that we are not hard
coding the name and then same thing for
our bucket
dot website dot name so now you can kind
of relate why this name here in the
double quotes is a reference in
terraform but not the actual name of the
bucket because we can repurpose it in
different blocks later when we are
creating resources that are dependent on
the initial resource
will give the role to through this ACL
as reader
and the entity which can be a user a
single user a group in our case I want
it to be public so all users
and there we go so far we have created
three resources in our main.tf one of
them is the storage bucket where we'll
store our website contents the next one
is
a storage object access control which
allows the objects in the bucket to be
public since we want
people on the internet to be able to
access our website and then the third
resource in our main.tf is uploading the
index.html file from our website
directory to the gcp cloud storage
bucket so remember I showed you how to
create a service account and an API key
in gcp for our terraform project to be
able to authenticate we will use that
key now
so what I want you to do is copy that
key that you downloaded then to your
project directory right now so I'm gonna
do that as well so in my route of the
project directory I'm just gonna paste
the key
and as you can see the Json key that I
downloaded is now in the root of my
project now we will use this key to
authenticate terraform to gcp to deploy
resources and that's where you can see
how you know we had this segment in our
provider.tf where it says credentials
use file and then we are referring to a
variable called dot gcp underscore
service underscore key so let's create
variables.tf in our infra folder
and here we will declare the variables
we need to have for our project which we
haven't done yet even though we were
specifying it in the provider.tf so
let's go ahead and do that the first
variable is gcp service key so gcp
underscore service underscore key and
I'm going to leave the other arguments
blank for now
the next variable is gcp project and the
last one is gcpe region
and again I'm Gonna Leave the arguments
for these variables blank for now so
let's save that and there are multiple
ways you can assign these variables the
values so you can either do it during
running the terraform CLI command or you
can provide with the TF vars file so
let's go ahead and create that too let's
name it
terraform.tf Wars
so let's for an example let's say you
wanted to deploy this to a Dev
environment in your gcp and you had a
different project so you will specify
the details of the dev environment in
this terraform.tfrs and similarly you
will have a different TF Wars file for
production environment which you can
call
prod.tf Wars and that would have you
know project ID of production
environment region of production
environment and a service key that
allows access to the production project
instead of the dev ones so you can see
how you can use the dot TF Wars file in
you know different cases so in our case
since we only have one environment let's
go ahead and assign those variables
value so the gcp
service key is the first one which
allows us to authenticate terraform to
gcp so that it can deploy infrastructure
and I'm gonna copy the name of my
service key here
and paste it
so now I have my service key next
variable was gcp project and it's
literal Academy
314813 and you can find your project ID
in the gcp console which we created in
the beginning of this course so if you
go to your console in browser and if you
click on projects remember I created
Youtube and you can get the ID of that
project from this screen
so going back to TFR files let's go with
gcp region which is the last variable
I am closest to us East so I'm gonna use
Us East today to deploy my website so
there we go we have assigned the
variables that we defined in
variables.tf some values according to
our need and I'll save that file
and let's go back to main.tf and now
let's deploy the bucket and see if our
terraform code works so right now what
I'm doing is
since we have the code for cloud storage
all figured out in terraform let's try
deploying this
and see if we have an object called
index.html in our bucket in a cloud
storage so what I'm going to do is open
up the terminal let's clear the screen
and now let's go to the directory of my
project which is called terraform with
gcp and now let's change the directory
to infra because that's where our
terraform files are and now in order to
initiate the terraform project you have
to do terraform init
so this will generate some boilerplate
files that are needed like the state
file and I'll explain what it does
so let's do terraform in it it will also
go and check the provider that we are
using so in our case we are using
hashicops Google Provider from their
registry and you can see it's installing
that provider and we can also see that
terraform has been successfully
initiated
so if I go back to my code editor we'll
see a bunch of files
that were created in a directory called
dot terraform was created this is where
the state files will exist and what I
mean by state is once we deploy our
bucket now
let's say we want to destroy it or we
change something in our main.tf it'll
remember the infrastructure State the
last time we did a terraform apply so
let's say we
add load balancer and we add Cloud CDN
and Cloud DNS it will not create the
bucket again because it already had done
that and you'll see this once we do
terraform apply since it can remember
the state of the infrastructure it will
not deploy the bucket again but would
just deploy the changes which is adding
Cloud DNS Cloud CDN and load balancer so
that's what all these files are let's go
back to our terminal and do terraform
plan so terraform plan basically tells
you what all resources would be deployed
so it won't actually deploy the
infrastructure but just give you an idea
of what all resources will be deployed
to gcp in our case so you can see
there's the bucket there's the
index.html and then there is the object
Access Control public rule that we
created So the plan says three to add
zero to change and 0 to destroy so this
is what I meant by state now let's do
terraform apply
yes
so it went ahead and added all those
three resources
now if we go back to my Google Cloud
console and we navigate we navigate to
cloud storage we should see a bucket
named example website so search for
cloud storage and you can see we have an
example website by reshope that was just
created so let's click on that it has an
object called index.html which is
according to the public access it is
public to the internet
so let's open that
it has a public URL let's try to visit
that
and there we go that was the website we
had locally right so this is localhost
Port 5500 that I showed you in the
beginning the index.html that I created
and this is on the Google Cloud Storage
so our site is basically live but we are
still accessing the object directly from
the storage what I would like to have is
a load balancer in front and
Cloud CDN which will help us with
caching the content of our website and
DNS which would give our site a more
friendly domain name so yeah we have
been successful in deploying the three
resources we defined in our main.tf now
let's move forward with the load
balancer CDN DNS so let's go ahead with
the next part of our architecture which
will be using the load balancer and one
thing with load balancer is that you
will be given an IP address and I want
to make sure that IP address is static
not Dynamic so what I'll do is reserve
an external IP before I create the load
balancer so let's go ahead and do that
so I'm gonna make a comment saying
reserve a static external IP address
and then what I'll do is create that
resource so resource and the way you
create an external IP is Google
underscore compute underscore Global
underscore address and then we'll call
this website underscore IP so the name
can be and this is the name that will go
in gcp so website
let's put lb which stands for load
balancer and then IP and we are good so
that gives us an IP that will be
reserved for us that we'll use later in
our load balancer also so the way I have
set up my DNS zone I'll show you in gcp
so since we are talking about IP address
for our load balancer let's also go over
how we will configure the domain name
so what you have to do in order to
configure the domain name is you have to
first enable the cloud DNS service you
can already see that I have a Zone name
reshap Dash example and it has a DNS
name
gcp.reshup.cloud so you could have any
domain name service provider like
namecheap or Google domains or Route 53
but what you will have to do is either
transfer that domain name to Cloud DNS
or you can create a zone for a subdomain
so let's say I want to create a zone for
this project called terraform Dash gcp
the DNS name that I own is reship.cloud
so I'll create a sub domain here called
test.reship.cloud and then for the other
settings you can leave it default and
click on create so what it'll give you
is a list of name servers and if you
click on the NS record you can see those
four name servers that the cloud DNS for
gcp uses and what you will have to do is
go into your domain name server service
provider so namecheap or Route 53
and create this record with the DNS name
test Dot reship.cloud and the type being
name servers which is NS and paste all
these four values in there the DNS
propagation can take some time and
that's why I already have the example
Zone setup that I'll be using in this
project which points to
gcp.reshup.cloud so since I already have
the DNS Zone created what I want to do
here is not to create it but get
D managed zone so get the managed DNS
Zone and how you can do that is through
data so data Google DNS managed Zone and
then what the name of that zone will be
in this terraform file so let's name
that DNS Zone pretty straightforward and
now we will get that data from the gcp
provider so in my case the DNS Zone was
named reship Dash example so just to
clarify we are not creating the Zone we
are getting it from the Google cloud
provider says since it already exists so
now let's add that IP address that we
reserved to this DNS Zone
so add the IP to the DNS so that the
name translation happens fine so if we
go to
website.gcp.reshup.cloud it translates
to whatever the reserved IP points to
the load balancer
and let's name this website
so the name that I want is website dot
but then I want to use whatever the DNS
Zone got us so you can use dollar sign
and then curly brackets and you already
see the terraform extensions that I have
installed is auto populating that DNS
Zone name so let's go ahead and type it
out instead so data and then I can copy
this manage DNS Zone record
it's called VNS Zone
and at last
it's DNS name so there we go the new
record that will be created for our
reserved IP would be something like
website.gcp.reshup.cloud and I could
have put in anything in front here it
would be
xyz.gcp dot reship.cloud so I hope you
understand what I'm trying to do here
the type since it is an IP address will
be a and not a z name and then TTL which
is time to live let's go with 300
seconds which is 5 minutes the managed
Zone that we will be using again we
don't need to hard code it we can just
use the zone that we got from gcp
earlier and at the end we'll not need
DNS name but just the name which is
vishub Dash example so instead of hard
coding this here I just am relying on
terraform to figure it out itself
now we have the RR details which is the
string data for the records in our case
since it's an A type record will be the
reserved IP address for the load
balancer
moving along let's add the bucket as a
CDN backup remember we are using a cloud
load balancer which will need a back end
to serve the content which is our bucket
so the resource before the load balancer
that we are creating is that backend so
Google compute back and bucket
and let's call it website Dash backend
and let's also name it website backend
and then for the bucket name we have the
Google storage bucket dot website.name
which it will pull up from here so this
is the bucket name that it'll get let's
also add a description to the to the
back end so contains files needed for
the website and this is where you also
enable CDN so enable CDN
is equal to true
so this will
enable Cloud CDN for us for our backend
bucket so we created the backend bucket
now let's create a URL map
so this is a property in the load
balancer which allows us to specify what
when a user enters a specific URL path
that is being served by the load
balancer what it should direct the
traffic to in our case it will be the
back end bucket that we just created so
let's go ahead and do that so resource
Google underscore compute URL map
and let's name it website of the name
can be website Dash URL Dash map the
default service that it's going to use
is the backend bucket that we build here
so you can get the name of that
back end is by doing Google underscore
compute underscore bucket dot website
Dash back-end dot self underscore link
and now we have to also specify the host
rules so host underscore Rule and this
is where you can tell like where the
traffic should be pointed to depending
on what host the user is asking for so
let's say you hosted in this bucket you
had images and videos and you wanted the
load balancer to manage that the traffic
based on the type of content that is
being asked for so you would have
something like slash images as the path
for images and then slash videos for the
video content and this property lets you
define those rules
so for a host I'm gonna go with anything
needs to be in double quotes
and you also need a path matcher so path
matcher for all paths and then we also
have to Define that path matcher so path
matcher name is equal to all paths
and default service
is our backend website
so so the back end that we created with
CDN enabled we need that so
it will be dot website Dash backend dot
self underscore link so this is where
all the paths will lead to which is what
I want because we don't have any spec
anything specific being hosted on a
different path I just want everyone who
accesses
xyz.reshup.cloud to go to the index.html
that is being served by this backend so
there we go we have our URL map setup
now let's create our load balancer so
the resource that we want now is the
Google Google compute Target HTTP proxy
and let's name it website again and you
can name the resources accordingly as
you like or if there is a specific
naming convention that you follow so
let's go ahead and for the actual name
in gcp let's call it website Target
proxy
and then the URL map that we created we
want to use that for this target proxy
so it'll be Google underscore compute
underscore URL underscore map
dot website
yep so we named it website
with entire form so website dot self
underscore link
so that is the URL map we want to use
and now we can go ahead
with creating the forwarding rule for
our load balancer so let's make a
comment saying gcp
forwarding rule
and then let's create that resource
okay so we have the Google compute
Global forwarding rule
and let's name it default in terraform
for the name in gcp let's call it
website forwarding root load balancing
scheme is gonna be external since we
need an external load balancer that
listens to internet requests IP address
and this is where we will use the IP
address that we blocked on the top
remember we had
a resource that would reserve a static
external IP address for us so we'll use
that here
so we can refer to it in terraform by
doing Google compute underscore Global
underscore address dot website
underscore IP dot address so this will
link that reserved IP to our load
balancer and then the IP protocol we
have to Define is TCP so listen to that
Port range so in terms of best practices
you should be using Port 443 here
and you'll need an additional resource
in order to do that is the SSL
certificate which you can get from gcp
and I can show you the code bit that's
required to get the SSL certificate but
the SSL certificate creation process can
take some time and hence for the
purposes of this demo I will not be
including the SSL certificate resource
itself so that's why I'm using Port 80
so that we have a working website that
is being served by a load balancer on
our custom domain and Target as you can
guess will be our proxy website that we
created here so Google compute Target
HTTP proxy dot website dot self link so
we have all the resources that are
necessary to according to the
architecture diagram we had so we we
have the cloud storage account that we
already deployed and we saw we could
access the index.html
we have the load balancer now we have a
backend that is being served by the load
balancer which has CDN enabled and we
have the DNS that we configured in our
main.tf so let's save our main.tf go to
our terminal here and do terraform plan
we'll see that it plans on adding five
resources instead of eight or nine
because we already deployed the bucket
and we also uploaded the index.html in
the previous terraform apply so this is
where the state comes in state remembers
what all infrastructure has already been
deployed from our terraform code
and it will not redeploy that again or
if we changed the index.html to
something else it'll have detected that
change and would have said one to change
so that's the concept of terraform State
file let's go ahead and do terraform
apply to deploy our changes to Google
Cloud It'll ask you to enter yes if you
are willing to deploy these changes
let's go ahead and do that and wait for
these changes to be deployed
okay so we have the apply complete we
have added five resources now we can go
to our gcp account and look for those
resources so the first thing I would
love to check is the load balancer so
let's go to load balancer
there we go
so you can see it did create a website
Dash URL Dash map which is a classic
HTTP load balancer and has a back-end
bucket
let's go ahead and look at it so this
was the IP address that was reserved for
us the backend bucket is the example
website by rishab which we wanted and
the cloud CDN is enabled
so basically we have deployed all of the
parts of this architecture diagram now
what we have to do is see if we can
access our website by going to this IP
slash index.html
so I'm gonna paste that in the URL bar
here
and there we go we have our website that
I wanted to be deployed to gcp being
served by the load balancer the next
thing to test would be the domain name
so if we go back to terraform file and
look at our DNS record set it's website
Dot and then whatever the domain name I
had in gcp which is gcp.reaship.cloud
and I can show you here because we
should see in Cloud DNS we should see a
new record so if I open that up we have
website.gcp.reshup.cloud
and it is pointing to the IP address of
the load balancer that we just visited
so now terraform did it part where it
created that DNS record and pointed it
to the load balancer IP let's just test
it out so website.gcp dot reship.cloud
index.html
and there we go we have our website
being served on a custom domain with a
load balancer and the cloud CDN and
cloud storage as the bucket for our
project so that was
the project today we deployed all the
resources necessary using terraform to
gcp the one bit that I want to cover as
we're towards the end is is the https or
SSL certificate if you want to create
the external load balancer that's on
Port 443 which is the recommended
practice
so all of the code for this project is
available on GitHub if you ran into some
issue and I'll link the GitHub repo in
the description below but this is how
you can get the https certificate so you
have to create a resource called Google
compute managed SSL certificate and the
domain name for that which you can use
the previous resource we created
which was website.gcp dot reship.cloud
so I have gone ahead and did that but it
still needs some time for the SSL so to
be provisioned but you can see it is
getting an SSL certificate for
website.gcp.reship.cloud by which
my load balancer would be able to serve
traffic over Port 443 so the code will
be available on GitHub but that's the
way to get an SSL certificate and if you
want to clean up your resources you can
do that by doing terraform destroy which
will delete all the resources that we
just added so not only the five
resources but also the bucket that we
added in the beginning so you can see
the total resources to be destroyed are
nine so you can do that and clean up
your environment this also depends on
the state so that's how it knows that it
needs to delete nine resources but yeah
terraform destroys the command to clean
up those resources so yeah the important
commands for terraform are terraform
init which initializes your project
telephone plan which will tell you what
it plans on deploying terraform apply
which needs a yes argument for it to
deploy the infrastructure to your cloud
provider and then terraform to destroy
which also need a yes argument to
destroy all the infrastructure as it is
happening right now so all of our nine
resources have been destroyed one last
thing before you all go
wanted to mention is if you plan on
hosting your code on GitHub make sure
you have added a git ignore to the root
of your project and you have added the
service key to not be pushed to a public
GitHub repository because it's important
it's your API key that gives you access
to your Google Cloud account
so the template for the git ignore
includes some terraform State files too
and can be found on the same GitHub
repository that I've shared in the
description so you can copy that for
your own git ignore but make sure you
have added the service key to the bottom
of the git ignore so that was the
project we built today we learned
about terraform which is an
infrastructure as cold tool also great
principle in the devops helps you
automate all infrastructure things and
we also learned how you can host a
website in gcp by using load balancer
cloud storage and also how to have a
custom domain pointed to it I hope this
project helped you understand these
Concepts and I can't wait to see what
you build